I don't know if it's working.
Is it working?
Hello?
Can you hear me?
Oh, it worked.
Hi.
I will be a small shibby.
Small shibby.
Baby Small Shibby today.
Where is going to play some album, right?
I just want to get some stuff in this play.
No pressure.
Just hanging.
Just spending time.
I was just going to play by myself.
But I don't want to.
Hello?
Hey, it's you and it's me.
We're just hanging out as cool as can be.
My chair is very squeaky for some reason.
Hello, how goes it?
I just started.
I woke up, fed the babies by myself,
and I don't really have anything to do,
so I want to play some eldering.
Before I play Doom later.
Just comfy morning.
Hello, hi everybody.
My chair is extremely squeaky.
I might need to tighten this up.
This is just kind of impromptu scuff full stream.
Excuse me.
I'll probably keep the vibe up and stuff though,
so you don't have to worry about that
in terms of like FOMO and all that.
I'll move myself up a little bit.
Hello, hello, hi, hi.
Okay.
Arm.
Shippity.
Yeah, we're early.
Yeah, you can chill.
There's no berries in here.
Hi, hello.
Okay, boomie.
Oh, boomie knocked my water bottle off my desk.
I totally forgot about that.
Where did it go?
Oh, here it is.
He like freaked out and accidentally knocked it off
and then spazzed all the way over to my closet.
Hi, boomie.
What's up?
I have a pumpkin scone.
I want to take a bite of my pumpkin scone.
I haven't tried it yet.
I got it yesterday.
Arm.
Mmm.
How does it get carrot cake?
Does it give me carrot cake instead?
I don't know.
Either way, nice fall flavors.
What are you eating?
When we just tried to eat one of my nail clippings
from yesterday that I missed and I was cleaning.
Why would you want to eat that?
I don't understand.
Hello, Riefling.
Hello, Karam.
Hello, Arlitz.
Hello, Bling Heart.
Hello, Snow Berries.
Hello, Snippets.
Hello, Fim Pals.
What?
What's happening?
Oh, you told me to make space for you so you can lay down.
Is this what you're asking me to do?
There you go.
Here, I pushed some space.
Hey, why don't you lay down over here?
I can't see past your body.
Hey, over here, mister.
Come on.
But yeah, I was just watching some, like,
where some scotty fragments were,
so you'll probably hear me turn on my TV
just to look.
Oh, good boy, Bling, the spot I cleared through.
And yeah, that's really it.
We're just hanging out.
We're not, it's not really a serious stream.
Not that any of my streams are serious, but, you know,
you know how it feels.
I kind of just feel like hanging out.
BGM's loud?
Okay, thank you for letting me know.
I turned it down a bit.
Okay, from what I recall,
I know I was over here and there's, like,
something down here,
but I'm going to focus on getting the scotty fragments.
And there's one that I missed.
And like I said, you'll probably, what the heck,
I'm scared of me, you'll probably hear me,
like, turn on my TV and, like, play a YouTube video.
And yes, the person is male
that I'm watching the walkthrough of.
So, yeah, I don't really know what to tell you.
Why is it a sad day?
Dear God, how many layers do you just go?
I'm playing Elden Ring, I'm watching,
she'd be playing Elden Ring, I was watching.
Someone playing Elden Ring?
Mercy, yeah, Mercy's watching you play.
Okay, so there, wait, is it over here?
Yeah, there was a place that I missed
when running around.
I might...
There's a secret room I totally didn't notice, apparently.
My nose is itchy.
Oh wait, I went the wrong way.
Ow.
I can make it there.
Let's see if I can even make it there.
I'm pressing Y to climb.
Oh, he just missed me.
And then it's up here.
I'm going down here.
So, I didn't notice that next to the little scorpion boys,
there's a secret room I can't see.
With the...
Oh my God, I forgot about this guy being here.
I forgot about that.
And then if you keep going, there's a cross of Micola
with the Scottotru fragment.
And I didn't know that that was there.
Oh, I missed.
So, I only need to grab that.
Your arm is sinstral.
Wow, he's really trying to be like Jesus for real.
But yeah, that was the whole thing I just missed.
And also over here.
I'm sure somebody pointed it out.
I don't know what the drive bouquet is about.
But I might have missed not seeing it
if they pointed it out to me in chat.
It looks like there's more, there might be more stuff down there.
But I don't really care about that.
I only came for the Scottotru fragment.
Oh, but they do have me aggroed.
Okay, now I can leave.
I missed that.
And then I already did that one over there.
So, I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna see what the guy says next.
Good morning.
As I die.
Did I get that one?
I don't know if I got that one.
I must have, because I have the grace unlocked.
Let me just double check.
Because you can get to...
Why is this so funny?
You can get to plus 12 without major bosses.
So, I'm just trying to do that, you know?
Yeah, it does connect to the main map.
It's actually layered on top of it.
Yep.
What do I have marked on the map in this direction?
Oh, I don't know when I was...
Oh, because I was talking to...
No, I just want to unmark it.
Thank you.
I take this road.
I just want to make sure...
Excuse me.
Good morning.
Hello, hi.
Hello.
Oh, I'm totally missing the bridge I need to go on.
It's also really bright outside and my screen is dark
and my window is right behind my screen.
So, I'm just grabbing some fragments
or just hanging out.
I have my higher voice on
because I'm just in that sort of cutesy chill head space right now.
What is that? I don't know.
So, apparently there's another one.
I might have already grabbed it.
I'm thinking that I might have grabbed it.
I'm not so sure.
I must have because I've definitely run through here before
so I think I did grab it.
Yeah, I definitely did.
Okay, let me sit down.
I still don't have enough.
I thought I had more.
I don't.
So, let's see.
What else does this dude say?
Whoa, I actually skipped a hug.
Did I get that?
Yes, I definitely did.
Okay, I definitely grabbed the one over here.
I'm just kind of going through what this guy is saying.
Just to retrace my steps,
make sure that I've covered all the ground.
Okay, I already got one from Folie.
Okay, I already got that one.
Yeah, I'll keep talking faster.
What?
What the frick?
Did I get there already?
Hold on, you're going too fast.
I totally missed what you just said.
You didn't even say anything.
Yes, I did that.
Yep.
Okay, I did that before.
Okay, he said that they're next to this.
Yes, that is my TV.
This has really been me watching video guides while playing
because I just don't know shit learning.
It's not even like, I did this anyways for like a base game
because this is a type of game where I don't feel like...
Oh, hi.
Yeah, I'm happy that so many guys are glad to see me this morning.
I like streaming early.
I don't mind it.
I've already gotten all my stuff done, so you might as well.
You know me, you know me, you know me, you know me.
Going from the church, yes, I did.
I got that one.
Do you know how far you are?
But there is a big collection of four or five right at an optional boss.
I don't think I've done that.
I think I know which one you're talking about.
I haven't done those yet.
Hello, good morning.
Everybody's so happy to see me so early.
I didn't expect this.
Okay, so he said next to this one there's an encampment which is right over here
and that there should be one in here.
I think I'm not quite sure.
Am I, did I get it?
Oh, there is one right there.
What the frick?
I thought it, I missed that.
That's like just literally there.
What the hell?
I could have sworn I ran through there, but apparently not.
All right, well, let's take, let's pop a squat.
Simply she be caught in peak.
Okay, yes.
All right, so now I'm at eight, so that's cool.
We're getting on with that.
What the fuck?
All right, talk to her.
Okay.
Yes.
Yes, I was in there.
It sucked.
Okay, I got that.
Oh, okay, that's why I get that map fragment.
That makes sense.
Wait, did I already get that crease?
Oh yeah.
Oh, I already, what the fuck?
I'm stupid.
Fuck, anyways.
Why would it do it all the way back there?
Did I grab that one?
Is that one all the way up here?
Is that what he's talking about?
I need to look at the map again.
Yep, just click and scatter tree fragments.
Surprise, surprise, it's me.
Just a really boring farming stream, but if some of you guys like to watch me just talk
and I know sometimes, I know me personally.
I like to have somebody in the background while I'm doing stuff.
So hi, it's me.
I'm in the background and you're doing stuff and you're being productive, right?
It's called shibbity fragments.
It's funny, I was watching someone and they're like the skadoosh fragments, the shibbity toilet,
the shibbity toilet fragments.
They were just calling the scatter tree fragments something different each time,
but with like incomplete seriousness and I was just dying and I couldn't focus on the video.
Okay, so that's...
Okay, so it is up there, so let's do it.
Do I have anything marked on my map?
I'll find out in a second.
I do, it's the one.
Where's the one pointing at?
I hate when I mark something on my map and I can't find it again.
Oh, I'm not facing the right direction, that's why.
Oh, I already marked, I'm stupid.
Alright, let's go.
Yeah, you can like, don't worry, I'm just hanging out.
I'm just chilling.
I'm just hanging out.
Yeah, I'm here, you're gonna be productive.
You are having a productive morning.
If you're playing Elden Ring, like me, you're productive.
If you gotta get chores done, do it productively.
We're gonna avoid this fire golem, motherfucker, that's all I'm gonna say.
That's all I'm gonna say.
Did I grab this one? I don't know.
I'm not quite sure.
Okay, so we said, oh, okay.
I didn't even grab that one.
Ah!
Bye.
Bye, I'm teleporting.
She didn't wanna work today.
No, but you have to, you gotta work today.
I know it's hard, I know it's hard to get up and it's just like, it's kind of mentally exhausting
and you don't wanna deal with people, but you got this.
You gotta do it, you gotta get that bag, sis.
You gotta get out of that car, lonely, glizzy, and you gotta go do work.
And then you'll be able to come home and relax.
It's all about what you make of it, you know?
You just gotta have a good day.
You just gotta make sure you have a good day.
You gotta have that mindset.
You gotta have that grind set, you know?
She beats against mental?
Yeah, 100%.
You know, you just got out of work?
Oh my.
European, European alert.
Euro alert.
Okay.
Oh, Boomi's so cute next to me.
He just wants to hang out.
Hi.
Why do you curl your toes when you're sleeping?
You're the only kind of man that does that.
See, like curls his back toes.
Give me them.
Give me them beans.
Ewww.
Alright, what's the next one, boy?
Yep, I just got that one.
Facts, bro.
Oh my God, Jesus Christ.
There's so many people in the camp.
Did I?
I don't think I went to the church at a crusade.
I don't think I did.
Oh, no, I did.
I did.
Where?
Oh, yeah, because then I fought.
Oh, no, I didn't fight him.
People were like, why where was he?
Wait.
I didn't mean to press that.
I pressed my controller instead of my remote.
What are you doing?
Uh, my remote.
What are you doing, boomi?
What are you doing, bro?
Hello, hi.
I found out from Helldivers too that Europeans
have three months mandatory vacations
because B Team of Devs made a bunch of crap updates
and the ones coming back from vacation are pointing out fires.
Really, interesting.
I didn't know that.
I did not know that.
There's something else in this church that I think I missed.
I don't think it's a scat-o-tea fragment.
I think it's something else.
I don't know why it's showing my runes.
I don't know where I died.
Because to be honest with you,
normally when I first played Elden Ring,
my first playthrough, I really sat through the game
and went and discovered everything,
but that takes hours.
And this time, I'm kind of like,
I want to defeat bosses so I can get some good weapons
because Rolana's swords are pretty nice.
Although I do have...
Oh, hi.
I do have...
Oh my God, please jump over the wall.
I do have the backhand swords,
but the blue skadoo fragments...
The blue skadoo we can, too, fragments are...
It's literally leveling, essentially.
I also have a lot of sombers that I could use
to level up weapons.
So did I miss something over here?
Oh, it was a rune arc.
Okay, that's still pretty good.
I'll just hang out here for a second.
Will Vila ever play Helldivers together?
It would probably just be us screaming.
What is that?
Oh, it's the chat.
The chat is just freaking out.
Don't worry about it.
Ah, red tracks!
It lost track of the...
It lost connection to you guys.
Here, I'll put you guys right there.
No, it wasn't something dangerous.
It's like the...
So I use this extension thing as a website.
It's giving me to...
I almost threw up in my mouth.
To connect to YouTube chat, so...
Sorry.
Because the double up, the liquidity double up.
All right, my hand is itchy.
What next?
Okay, I already did that before on accident.
You didn't say what the grace was, though, bro.
You didn't say what the grace was.
Okay, now I can see the said grace.
You're talking...
You didn't actually show the grace.
It's...
There's one over here.
Oh, I thought I did open this area up.
Did I climb up here and just didn't go over to this edge?
I must have.
I think I'll go here.
And then here.
And then we'll do that.
Bunspeak is my higher voice.
And so when people are just getting on my heads up...
If they're like, why is she talking so cutesy?
Yeah.
Because I feel like...
Oh, la-la-la-la-la-la-la.
What was that?
One material...
Oh, it's a dog.
Never mind.
I can't see the light.
Hi, sheepies.
Is it...
Oh, this is where I fought the dragon?
Well, I didn't fight him.
He's just fighting other dudes.
Okay, so I literally just didn't go to this edge part.
Hello?
Oh, I need to break the rocks.
It's over here, because that's why I'm...
I thought I already did this.
Yes.
I am aware.
Thank you for letting me know.
Yippee!
Yeah.
Alright, cool beans.
New area, bros!
Um...
Oop.
Oh, fuck it.
Pulled me out of the thing,
because of the stupid thing.
Oh, fuck it.
Pulled me out of the thing,
because of the stupid bird.
Stop!
I can't see you.
Ow.
Get down with your bats.
Ow, there's two of you?
I thought you were a statue.
I can't.
Ow.
You're doing too much damage for no reason.
Okay!
Pick up.
Thanks for the spinning stone.
What stinky monkey...
Goal!
What are you talking about?
I'm just...
I'm not gonna listen to you anymore.
So then...
over here...
there should be a thingy, my barber.
I know.
Never assume,
because it makes an ass out of you and me.
That's what I say.
There it is!
No.
Pull me his eyes.
He's sleeping with his eyes open,
as cats sometimes do,
because of their secondary eyelids.
Or their third eyelids, rather.
And he's just...
Oh.
There's stupid fucking birds following me still.
And then his mouth is open,
so he looks possessed.
Why do you look possessed?
So, like, we play as a monkey
and hear people talk about the...
Oh!
You mean...
Why don't you just say Black Myth Wukong?
You fucking dork.
Well, that doesn't really lead to anywhere.
Well, it does.
I just can't get there yet.
Let's get some...
Empyrean Blood Virgium.
It's Papa Squat.
How am I doing?
I'm doing good.
Now, I'm a Skadu Tree Blessing 9.
Pretty nice.
Pretty good.
Look how...
Can I change my armor?
I swear I have better armor.
I have a Black Knight Helm,
but it makes me heavy.
Guilty hood.
I don't have a lot of stuff
because, again, I was a speedrunning shit.
I could have sworn I had...
When did I get the deathbed dress?
All their stuff.
There's a set of armor I thought I grabbed,
but I feel like I just see people play
and then I think I did it myself in my own game.
It's just not the case.
You know?
Found Black Knight Gear.
Yeah, like I've heard that, too.
Yeah, we're just comfy farming.
I need a sit.
Let's check on my Tamagotchi.
Drop something.
I don't know what it was.
Oh, my God.
Tamagotchi's sick.
Sick of my shit.
Right, Boomi?
Right here, show.
Take a bath.
Okay, let me have a bite of my pumpkin scone.
Although it tastes like carrot cake, so...
I think they lied to me.
Oh, you put this on New Game Plus?
Yeah, it's not gonna...
I made a whole new save for that.
It's really good.
No, it's still alive, surprisingly.
Yeah, I played this before,
but I played it on my PlayStation,
not on my computer.
Okay.
Ow.
Yeah, I don't have any new Game Files.
Hello.
Mm-hmm, m-hmm.
Okay.
I was gonna read Icy after streaming for a bit and I realized it's the members and I
was like oh I guess I'll just have to play longer then.
I'm gonna have FromSoft Enjoyer.
I've only ever played Elden Ring and I played like five seconds of Sekiro
so I can't really claim that. I'm a souls-like enjoyer.
You're watching The Room Today? I thought you were...
I thought it was an ASMR.
They look at the wrong day.
That was yesterday? Oh I must have been looking at the wrong day then.
Silly, silly me. How was that? How was the ASMR?
I need to learn from Icy's ASMR ways.
Okay, what did he say? Where did I? No, I didn't do the next one.
Sekiro is your least favorite song from software game and then I beat it. It's my favorite. Nice.
I did it.
How the fuck am I supposed to get to the Serlian coast?
All right boys, looks like we're going on a trip.
Looks like we're going on a trip in my favorite rocket ship.
How the fuck... Wait, how do I get down there? He just explained it.
He said go down here and then go here.
What the... What the fuck are you talking about bro?
Why are you going in? Why are you in your feelings in my chat right now dude?
Like you're welcome to hang out but what are you on?
What the fuck? Yeah, there's a few ways. I'm looking at one way.
We're talking about Elden Ring. Good vibes only bro. Good vibes only.
I don't have the maps for this.
Lily was the energy though. I was a little confused there.
This is not emo boy hours. This is cute girl playing Elden Ring hours. We have emo boy hours
when Shibani is here. Ever since Melina, don't me, it's never... See if you do it like that then
that's fine. If you frame your trauma in Elden Ring then I will allow it.
If you frame all of the trauma dumping in Elden Ring, if you make it Elden Ring relevant,
I will allow it. I will allow it.
Stop laughing.
I'm dying.
Hey, I'm just gonna go this way.
Yeah, you can trauma dump your hatred for bail.
The dragon.
The laughter must continue for stream entry.
Hi Shibi, how's it going? Professor Chico is here. Great to see you again.
Hola, Professor Chico.
To Keres? I'm kidding.
I'm made in this. That's my trauma. It's okay bro. Do you guys want like dating advice?
But like framed, but framed as an Elden Ring? Am I gonna die? It's fine.
How the fuck?
Yeah, all right. So what type of gal are you talking to? What's her speed?
Like is she like kind of like a Malania type? Is she a Malina type? Is she a Rinalda type?
Is she a Rallana type? Is she, you know, like what type of gal is she, you know? What is this?
Shadow Ramoon. You're married? Congratulations. I'm so happy for you.
So it's a, it's a right card and what's her face type? I understand. Ronnie type.
I don't know. I've been listening to a lot of lore about Ronnie and I'm low key not liking her right
now. Like she's like, she's cool. Best character design IMO. Just saying. Is there a Grace down
here? Because I will kill myself in Elden Ring. And like everything she did to God one was kind
of fucked. Like why did she pick him? Like he was like actually the most like chill dude. I felt kind
of bad. She's a scrawny type. I don't know which person scrawny would be. Where am I? Oh it worked.
Nice. Nice. The fact there isn't a Grace at the bottom actually pisses me off though.
Fuck you little dudes. More of a Gwinnivere understood.
Can I please get a Grace? Can I please? I just want a Grace. Please. Can I have a Grace?
Can I please have a Grace? Please.
I don't know where I'm going. I kind of like, I'm aggroed by someone. Okay. I'm going the wrong way.
That's where I'm going. You lost the game. Who are, are you elderly?
God one was like my wife stole your dad. No not like God one the golden. You're thinking about somebody
else. Was God one dating his mom? I don't know.
Astroscience but elderly? No yeah I do need to go further down. I went the wrong way.
Cause what did he do? I actually went too fucking far I think.
Yeah yeah yeah.
I'm fucking stupid I went too far. Anyway so let's turn the fuck around buddy.
Yeah.
You'll date someone's mom? I, okay. God if I recall was married to Mary. What? No you,
you're thinking of God, like God free brother. You're thinking of God free brother. You're
getting your Gs mixed up thanks to fucking George R R Martin being a fucking weirdo.
Here we are. I can't see shit. Torrent help.
Wow what I've always wanted. A deep purple lily. It was God one, what?
What are you, I'm thinking of God when the golden. Am I, am I naming people wrong?
All right. Is someone telling me that God win?
Yeah there's God, God free is married, was married to America. God win was the son.
Then there's Godric and God of free. God of fry. I fucking hate George R R Martin for this.
Yes thank you. I know Gilbert Godfrey.
Well because it's George R R Martin's because you got G names, you got R names,
then you got M names. Just how it is.
Free my boy Godofroy. Godofroy. I can't even never pronounce his name.
I didn't play the game. Fuck you I'm getting one guide by my own, by my own harlots.
How dare. All right we're in this fucking cave. We're doing fucking cave shit. We're having a great time.
Something gonna attack me.
The fact that nothing is falling from the ceiling and assaulting me right now is
extremely weird. Oh nice. I'll have to do a revered spirit ash thank you. Oh finally.
Thank you. Thank you so much. You're a dude. You are. I thought you guys were all women.
A disney soul but souls born that means fucking sick.
Godfrey, Godwin, Godric, Godofrey, Gideon, Melina, Melinia, Melissa, and Ronnie,
Rinala, Rallana. I see all the main characters just like five times fast.
Lies of Dorothy. There's lies of pee. Lies of Dorothy.
What? Wait brother you're onto something. Imagine an Oz, a wizard of Oz, souls like.
I wouldn't be mad at all. I actually wouldn't mind that.
The lies of pee sequel is going to be Oz. Is that legit? Is that legit? They're making one?
Bro, I'm so happy right now. I love lies of pee. Oh my gosh.
Holy crap. I don't really care about Sonic. You can shoot me in the fucking head. I don't care.
I've never really been into Sonic. I played Sonic. I played a lot of Sonic when I was a kid
but I wasn't. I didn't have the autism for Sonic like everybody else does. Hi.
Bye bye. What? What? Don't look at me like that.
Everybody thinks like I want to fuck Sonic the headshot or the hedgehog.
Kingdom Hearts is pretty great. Kingdom Hearts but add Sonic.
I know, I know Amy would be really pissed off to hear me say the things I'm saying right now
because she's in love with Shadow. Oh no, no. I definitely was, I definitely like Rouge the bat.
Like I remember making my little chow garden and raising some chows.
Is it cows? Chows? Chails? I don't know.
Listen, my Tism was a wolf quest and wolf role playing. Okay, I don't know what to tell you.
I was not a furry but I played as a wolf online. It was mostly just writing and world building.
And all levels except physical, I am a wolf. Wait, how? Okay, what does he say?
Yeah. Oh, fuck, okay. Well, follow the water all the way southeast.
Is there a map nearby that I can... Jesus, fuck.
All the way... Oh, I can't see anything so it's probably gonna go all the way down there.
Oh my god, the map's all the way over there. Are you trying to kill me?
All the way southeast. Is that southwest? Southeast.
Why is the water golden? Who is pissing?
Oh, you want me to platform? Oh god, I can't do this. Ooh, what's that?
Torrent. Torrent! Torrent!
Torrent. I'm killing myself. Torrent. Torrent, please. Torrent. Torrent, I'm stuck. I'm literally fucking stuck.
I
Anger
I like this. I just sometimes I just hate platforming with torrent. I don't care about the runes to be honest with you. I really don't.
Um
Let's try this again. Torrent behave. What the?
I don't know what just happened there. I
I'm so confused. I don't know why
He literally does something. I don't know if I bumped my stick and it just Emily fucking just went to the side. I
What's that?
Can I have it?
Can I have it? It's a do-gem. Cool.
Do-gem
Mama like that. Oh my god. Torrent, please. Torrent, please.
It's like he's so hard to control platforming for me. I'm terrible at platforming in general. Um
So, yeah, you know how hard it was for me to go through blight town in lies of pee
I was literally just falling off every five seconds
Like lies of pee had so much platforming because you don't have a mount
And it's a lot more linear it's not open world
No, no, don't get it. Don't get me wrong. Sorry. I'm eating my skull
Torrent doesn't suck is the platforming with torrent sucks. I love torrent. I just can't platform on a horse
Unless it's Skyrim
Hello
Hmm
Yeah, because they kind of make torrent a little bit
Realistic in terms of if he turns he's obviously going to step a little bit forward
Like you're not going to just like do like a
You're not just going to like clip to the left or the right or something
Oh my god, let's just walk and do one jump. How about that?
I'm jump. I'm double jumping when I don't need to
Except for that time
See like look how he turns and it's very interesting. Um, where am I going?
He said keep following the water. Do I go down?
No, I think that leads into nothing
Oh my god
Uh, let's not do that
Can you just like all be statues, please I don't feel like dealing with you
Ow
Oh my god. Oh my why am I locked in a animation and then stones? I don't
All right, the moment I get on that spot, I'm going to get off torrent because I can't deal
And then if I need a platform again, I will summon him, you know, you know
Oh
Potentate what a word potentate
I I jumped okay. Thank you. That was weird. Oh, you know what let's just
You're absolutely fucking useless right now torrent. I can't see
I'm being chased by bug men. I wish I could double jump
Stop thank you. I still killed them in three hits. So that's like I need a better weapon, you know
What okay, well
I'm just stupid
All right, I'm making my way downtown walking fast birds attack and I'm homebound
Meow meow meow meow meow meow meow. Ow. I should have rolled
It's the same thing gonna happen again. Am I just gonna
They're like the uh, the fucking hawks from storm built. What do you do?
Like I don't recall you having this move set brother
Are they just built different over here?
I don't I don't know like how are you still alive?
Oh my god, just fucking die already. Jesus christ
Are any of you alive?
I can't tell because it's dark. Let me let me turn on the light here
What is this this is not gonna be worth it. Okay, it's actually fine. Um
Have a fine stream
Excuse me
Thank you
my goal
My designer everyone he's like a weird creepy uncle
Oh look
Are you sitting? No, I'm not do I need to because I'm not spending okay. I do maybe
What is happening why is there something on fire in the distance? I don't even
It's fine. I'm just gonna halt my little self down. I need an armor set
I need to see if there's any good armor sets
I swear there's one you pick up. It's it's it's I'm too far away from it now, but it's fine
Oh
Papa squat. Hey, let's talk to this dude
Hello
I was once told a coffin could convey its passenger upon a gentle cruise to the velvet garden of deepest pep
Oh to slumber in such a paradise
Sick brother, uh anyways, Emma did I go the wrong way? Is this leading me to st. Trina?
What's that deer doing
I don't know where any of this stuff is. I don't I'm getting ahead of myself. I I don't think st. Trina is over here
I don't know why I'm thinking that
It is
The gale the gale the jail night armor is nicer to beat the guy for you. I don't feel like beating dudes when I'm fucking weak as hell
Yeah, yeah, we're not using torrent. I'm just gonna fall and die off something and I'd rather fall and die my own two feet and my own terms
Actually torrent I might need you now
I could have gone down that way. I went down the the harder way
Death no
Why are my on fire? Oh, it's just me kicking up the road
As I run, uh, cool
Anyways
So I started blasting
I swear I saw why are you all?
I
That was I losing it. I swear. I saw our side of grace
Am I am I mentally sound no
Just golden sheep is there I could have
I
Don't think okay, maybe I'm just a Lulu. I'm just a Lulu
I'm delirious out of my mind. I remember watching that one. I was like good. That's funny
Oh, there's so many fucking golems. You're so huge
Why are you so big?
Sorry, I have to avoid the golem
um
I don't oh
Uh
How I forget how much fucking reach this dude has
Oh, I'm almost there ish. I don't fucking know
Can you diagram me please
Why why who's shooting lightning? It's just like fucking eltas plateau all over again
I kind of just want to look let me not be on torrent so I don't fall off
Oh, it's a spooky place. Oh spooky
The spooky spook
All right, let's look at the map
Then let's play the video
I said to beat dudes. Yeah off. Sorry. Oh
I
Sight of grass. Yeah, the fireballs are honing love crafty in play dark souls. Yeah, I know
Oh
What
Are you guys looking at me like that?
I forget sometimes I say something saucy and I forget that I said it and then you guys make that face
Okay
Yep, yep
Yep
How I don't have the map so I can't see it
Yeah
What I need like a 10 second rewind
Oh, okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. I understand
I understand I understand I understand
I did not recall. I didn't see that there's an area past the dude
I forget I'm standing in water
Why are they so big do I like can I kill you? I'm sorry. I'm just testing something
Oh, they get really angry and I shoot us when I kill a deer
A deer cheap
They make their own lightning very golden fleece. I'm pretty sure golden fleece is like some sort of
Thing
Okay, there is a cave
Or there's a place this way. Yes
Hello hi
No, I just learned some friames dropped
Hello, ooh, that's so cool. You're like a lightning schiep
Little schiepy scoop a spoopy-doop. Where am I? Whoa? Oh, this is so pretty
Oh, wait, no, I didn't mean to close what no apple tv. What are you doing?
I had
Directions, okay, this is so pretty
Wow
I remember seeing this in like trailer stuff, but I haven't like seen it for myself
Okay, we go down here
I think
There should be a why do I feel like a dragon should be coming out of here out of nowhere for some reason
Um
To be a mariner who what are those things? Oh, I don't want to know nevermind
It's like an undine undine undine undine
Grace what is that?
Pretty the water's kind of muddy
They do have to say should they should you know worry about pollution
Who is Yoda
What's in is there am I right is there a dragon is there a dragon in the fucking middle
There's always dragon dragons have the biggest arenas
Is
The dragon gonna fucking come out of nowhere and kill me. Okay, what did he say so then
Okay
From the west coast threat grace, I'm just gonna run east
Oh, Yoda has a cool sword is that the the guy where the fuck did the grace go um brown east and then over here
This is so pretty holy shit
If only I had a map
Is there a map nearby? Oh
There's one right there. Okay. I might go back and grab that
I don't think I can actually it's probably in the fucking water where I can't reach it
The maps are really hard to get to hold on before something aggro's me
Is
Okay, all right, let's continue
I'm on the way to Yoda's sword. What the fuck am I doing?
Get the fuck back on the horse slash goat slash ram. Okay, so it's over here. I gotta kind of hug the wall
You
Is this a cave nope, oh, there's magic dudes with the health
Uh, no point, please
Over here
Oh
Wyme wasn't locked on
There's quite a weird spot
The LC's going well the move it's in this area
So we
How do I get it don't come on me
ow
Where that I don't like those little blow where do I go help
Oh
Go back and then go east. Okay. I need to heal
We're into my ass trolls
Look at these little noodle dudes
Oh
Gumi I'm I'm not sorry. I'm looking at my cat's toe beans. It looks so delectable
That's funny tickling my cat's toes because then they like this for their little toe pads and their little feet. It's very cute
How do they call me Yoda?
Gonna do that
Going east and south will lead to the map and then we've got a tree next to
That gold thing north of the map after
That's uh, I mean this thing
I
Feel like I should go for the map because that's just uh, let's see where you can go for the map
Because at east
This flips with a magic sword nice
Was he also taught by the blind swordsman?
I don't know what this is
Ow
Oh my god torn
East and south, uh, well, I can't really go east and okay, so it actually is in that direction where the map is
Who the
The fuck oh, it's a shade
Sorry, I'm trapped in a 15 hour long animation for some reason
Sorry, I'm tied up say BDSM. I'm not gonna be able to kill you am I? Oh, yes, I am
The fuck odds do you drop anything? No stupid
Pretty
Oh level design we stan
There's my little blue beam there it is
Yep, I thought this was all ocean dragon
Who are you is it bale?
I don't know who are here's the rain and fucking dragon
Doing dragon shit
Feel like I'm playing skyrim over again
Yeah
Yay a map. I'm the map. I'm the map. I'm the map
Um yay now I can see all baby
I can see
I can show you the world
Now you want to go west and north to a grace in a scotter tree west north
You
Thank you for using cardinal directions by the way, I appreciate that
What is that
West and north what?
Huh, huh, there seems to be ocean there
So, uh
All right east and then north okay. Thank you. Thank you for the assist
I'm wondering what those little laser things are called
Oh
Oh perfect
Class do Mikula
Yep
Reach out and touch grace
Can I upgrade
No, okay. What was he I feel like he was gonna send me this direction anyways
What
That's a dragon
Fuck
What are they doing? Oh, it's all the way over there
That's over there
Hello, hello, hi, welcome in
I yeah, I noticed the chat froze I just
Didn't care
Your t-fees are sticking out I can see your t-fees
Oh, you did did you chip your tooth again? Oh my oh
Oh, give me those toes
Oh, did you have to blow boomie your feet are hanging off the desk. How is this comfy for you?
Yeah, that was a weird bug I was like I was really pissed because I was just I was still up I was just um
I was watching Elden Ring stuff as I do and um
I went I was looking at the short not the short. I was looking at vtube studio vtube. I can't talk I was looking at
YouTube studio on my phone and I was I clicked on it to see if there was any clips
And as I clicked on the clips it only showed me that there was 29 minutes and I kept doing that and I was like what the
Fuck is happening?
Yeah, I don't know how to fix that. That's just oh
Boomie, are you running in your sleep? What's happening here son? Your legs are twitching ridiculously
Oh, thank you for the toes put those grippers away. I think he's dreaming
I think he's dreaming
You were going the right way for the sword. What do you mean? Well, where do I go for the sword?
I want the sword I want it
You
Earlier but I went for the oh when I was back where I was looks like a giant horse over there. What is that?
Oh
Wow torrent relax, I know you're excited. I want to see the dragon. Oh, let's go look at the dragon
Actually, you know the dragon looks like it's too far to get to
Hello, oh
Those things are like too strong for no reason. Ah
How do you even kill those? Oh, no, how am I alive? How am I alive?
How
How do I oh looks like we're going towards the dragon
Why is there a random finger monster here? That's like very random. I think ease. How do you know baby thingies?
Just feeling I'm having flashbacks to what a gargoyle was. What the fuck is this? Oh
I'm hoping it's weapons and it's never weapons. I don't know what I'm thinking. Um, hi
Hey, oh my god. Oh, oh god. No
Help
Help I'm being assaulted. No
No
Stop leave me alone. Where are you?
Where are you? I can't lock on I'm just gonna run away
I'm running away
Flee flee
Flee to the underwater sea utopia
Okay, oh dragon dragon is not
No, I can't get to the dragon
Oh
Wait
I
I'm near another finger ruin. What's a finger ruin?
Is it not
No torrent it's hard to tell in the terrain where there's cliffs
Very difficult
All right, so where okay, I'm back at the map thing
You know what let me just focus on what I was doing. I'm getting way too distracted. I'll get the sword leader
I'll get the sword leader. I finished my scone. I'm very sad
Where did my remote go? Oh, it's in my lap
Okay, so he said what do you what the fuck was that boomie? That was the weirdest stretch I've ever seen you do
Hi
Hi, big man. Are you switching? Are you laying on your other side?
Oh, good boy. Oh, would you good boy hanging out with me? Thank you
Being so well behaved
I wish I had a blasphemous blade
You
What the fuck
Oh look for the dragon is
Okay, that's a lot
That's a that's a lot brother
So I have to
Jesus fuck, okay
This is trying this is all of this avoiding bosses because I'm trying to get my levels up and shit
Oh
No, I'll let you know and I want to be back
Oh, like okay, like okay since since we got to go all the way over there and I don't feel like looping all the way around
Uh, where's the where is the where's where is
Where is the sword?
Where is master Yoda's sword? Why are they calling master Yoda? Does he look like master Yoda?
I'd drag it in the background for scared me for a second because I forgot it was there
Is it just like a little small dude?
Thank you guys for helping me
All right, I'm here I'm ready to rumble
What did I kill it has that much rooms?
I
Mean a sacred text
Northeast okay, is it through that same area that I went to where I where I took
Okay
Gotcha gotcha gotcha gotcha gotcha
Yippie
Hi
Really is a deer are super small in this game. It's kind of funny. They're like mini deer
Because deer should be like as big as torrent
Now what which way western man? There's a there's a fork in the road. Why can I summon here?
Hello welcome in we're playing
And down the left path facts keep going facts
You turn on the light
You look like angry markers
Wait what?
Right into a wall don't worry about it
Okay
Which way western man hurry before they shoot me
Do I keep going northwest?
Straight okay
All right, don't you fucking die don't have any roll berries
It's going to the beach beach ninky minjaj
Huh is that a ship or those ruins it looks like a part of a ship, but I think it's just ruins
And that's our boss that's a boss
Oh
Or do I kill him
They're coffins. Oh shit coffins for the demigods he has the sword
Kill him all right
I missed
Oh
How do you all have red eyes like you're dragon I'm not lost on to you
I took the turn off auto lock and it kept fucking me up
Oh, I have to kill a demi something or other or is that a troll? What are you? Um
I
Come over here
I need to do some crowd control before I uh
The fact that they haven't aggroed me yet is very impressive. Oh now they have
That's fine
I'm out of juice
You have a weird looking face brother
I
Why are you so weak to magic but you're sorcerer I'm quite confused by this
Now hate bloodstones let me back up. Oh, there's so many of you
Oh
God there's so many little fucking trolls guys have a beach day or something like
I kind of wish they were faster than her
Or at least she was faster than them because they all run at the fucking same speed
I
Am out of stuff
Oh, you killed your own guy. Thank you for that. I appreciate that a lot actually
I don't quite understand that spell. I thought I turned out a locking off
Okay
Oh
Starline sword do they all die? Oh, they did uh
Interesting
Cool katana time
I can't even hold. Oh, I can't use it
Let's go level it up, baby
Oh, I didn't mean to do that
I
I'm Virgil who's Virgil what the hell
Why is it look so small
I feel like I feel like the other katana was longer. Um hot. No wrong place
Hello
Going the wrong way
Hey, I know I haven't been here in a bit
Oh, don't let me cry. Oh, okay. Yeah, you're right. I didn't I totally fucking missed that
Yes
I am the storm that is approach. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Sorry. I told I went over my head. Why I'm you trained here
Oh, okay, you're a prisoner
Well, no grudging my being a pretty sign despite my different sides it helps me
Anyways
Why is somber 8 so hard to find
Oh
Yeah, lunch hour
What time is it? It's over 37. What can I have for lunch? That's a great question
I had my scone
Yesterday I had some rice and salmon. I could make rice and salmon again
I
Can buy I don't have the ball bearings for that. I know exactly what I had didn't never went to that cave. Um
Oh
Because it's with the crystal ladies, right the two it's a it's a dual thing
Are you saying there's no somber 8 and
What do you call it lands
In shadow lands
And escape the shadow land borderlands
Pizza maybe you get a new armor set bro, what the fuck am I wearing?
Um
Because I could
Go to the fucking oh my god, why I got is like a random barrel
And then like a random dude
It's it I bet there's some lower significance here
Of a little guy
In his front and is the child
Yeah, I feel like when it comes to sombers, it's just like in in chat the shadow
The land of shadow. It's literally just a fucking
Like randomizer like here you go
Wait the bell bearing for the I didn't even unlock for a Missoula
Slap that in there
I didn't even bother with farm Missoula. It's like I hanging out by its loesome
Where's that black dot? Oh never mind. That's a thingy
And I also didn't even lock like the mount top of the giant it's because I was speed running shit
Um
I
Let me do a quick search
Excuse me
Oh
Okay, I see what you mean by the forge I wasn't I wasn't familiar with what you were talking about
Oh, I need to fucking press back on the screen. Um
Because it is I did I didn't go up. I never went up from the ancient ruins
Kind of want a burrito
I might get a burrito
A little burrito
It's dark
No
Hello, good morning. Good morning
I can't see why is it so dark in this game
There's so many graves
Waiting for somebody to grab me and kill me. Good morning star sign the earth says. Oh, please
Please torrent. I know you can climb
Never been here before
I
The fuck just yelled
Welcome to my mind. All right, let's
Yeah, we're cat and everybody I have a purrito. Tell me I should eat boomi. I don't want to eat boomi
All right, who's gonna jump out
Why does this look like fall game? Oh wait? No, I was here. What?
What
No, I was in a different forge
Where was the other forge I was in before?
What the fuck this looks exactly the same
Um, I presume I do not to jump
Okay
Hit them where they're weakest the pee pee
Skadoosh
Yeah, I get to stand in lava without getting hurt
Okay, we got ourselves a ladder
Neat
Anybody over here anybody doing cool flame stuff
Nope
Wait, hold on. All right, look at this video. It's only a minute long
Okay, so they run and they go
Bro is running bro is jumping down. He might even use the ladder. He just flips off. What a fucking shad
Okay
Dump something goes up thing
Hmm
Looks to the side
Goes all the way to the top of the thingy
Oh, I see
Goes over there. All right
Walking walking walking
And our she goes all right
It's not that bad at all
Do some sick stuff, uh
Kind of surprised there's no enemies like attacking me right now
The only thing that's gonna attack me is myself
Because you went to the top of this here
You look down
Oh, what what's over there?
There's a dude over there. I can want whatever that is. Is it red?
Looks red
Looks like it's yellow
Is that an enemy?
That didn't do jack shit to you. Uh, I shouldn't have woken you up. Should I?
Hey, oh there's two of you
Oh sick actually
I had 150 runes, when did that happen?
What the fuck
When me is passed out on my desk
All right
I would like my runes back, but I don't know how to get back up afterwards
He like did a jump roll off I was impressed with that skill
And you went down here and you jumped in girls
But how do you get back after you jump down because my
Where are my runes?
They're in there for some reason
Well, I can always go back for them. Wait, where did he go after this? I forget
You went up to the top here look over there. Oh, yeah, then he jumped over here. Yeah
And then can't I think he went straight down here. Yes, and there's a somber
Uh
That's not that bad. Okay, and then I can go get my runes
Yo
Hi
There's a lot. Oh, um, this is awkward
Oh, what I don't know what's happening
Oh, um
What is up with this fucking sword? Oh my god, what?
What or do it am I just am I am I gone here am I this is it?
Oh, no, I could have gone back up. Okay
I
Keep hitting the skill to do follow-ups interesting. Okay, I feel like I'm still not that strong
Don't think so be enough cool jump super hero landing
I thought oh, I think he does that to avoid the stamina burn out
Jump
Uh
Does he I don't quite understand
How do you get back go oh, I see and then you jump. Okay. All right. All right. All right. All right. Now I get it
Oh
I actually press the forward button
I'm doing silly stuff
It's fine. It's it's where it need I need to be um, it's where I need it to be because then I can just jump grab it and jump off the edge
That was silly silly mistake
Yeah, maybe I need to rescale because I think I'm like de-scaling to be honest with you
But I also just need to kill bosses so I can get better fucking better runes
Rune drops. Yeah, it's not fucking die. She be come on
Oh
No
Guys I can't
I'm just a loser. I I should just put down the game and quit quit while I'm behind
I
I'm just waiting to fall off of this part and like jump off the edge and accidentally like I almost just did and then um
No
She be she be she be stop panic jumping stop panic jumping she be
What's over here focus focus
Hey
I could ruin some bosses. Yeah, I didn't like kill right car or mouth Keith or anything. No Keith. No, okay
What did you drop
A gas stone. Ooh
What they call me in middle school
I
Hello, welcome to harem emails
Gaston
Uh, all right
Let's go
Get me out of this cave
I
Something's gonna attack me
I can hear something making googly noises
No
Wait, I always go to the two fingers on accident
No, not you
I
No
Wait
Does this make a
Okay, I'm like does that make a difference I literally was here like five minutes ago
I need a nine
Okay, let me look it up
Oh
We're here for dog parents no, we're not
you
I
do
I think I grabbed the one...
What the fuck is he doing?
What is he doing?
No, I didn't scale the tree.
I mean, the thing.
I don't think I did actually go to this place for my nine.
Got the bail bearing.
Why? No, that requires me having to go kill people.
Hi, Shibi. It was nice meeting you in the club of Fuwa.
I wanted to support you, too, so it's lovely to be able to meet you.
Oh, thank you. Thank you for coming and checking me out again. Hi. Welcome back.
Keep working, Samar.
Oh, feel better. Feel better.
His headache sucked.
You know, go lay down.
My grating voice does not help.
Oh.
Meow. Meow.
What the? I can't see.
It's near a tree.
Is it over here? I forget. Oh.
Where on the map? Where on the map is it?
Okay, yes.
Somebody mentioned that...
Oh, there's a grace up here I just never got. That's so weird.
That's just so weird.
I didn't go over here, really, or grab the grace that's right here.
If you...
Well, if I need to upgrade another weapon, then if there's another bonus 8, then we'll have a great time.
Dragon.
Oh.
I'm even awake up in the morning. Oh, my God.
Don't hurt. Don't die. Thank God.
Don't also run off the cliff.
Yeah.
Hangin' out with the boys.
Why are they all just prayin'?
His dude fell out of his chair. That's too bad.
I just get the grace up here because I'm near it.
And I didn't grab any graces up here when I was doing my run.
Grab the map, but I didn't grab the grace. That doesn't make any sense to me.
Where is it?
Oh.
Pop a squat.
I don't know if I got hit or anything.
You spent 25 minutes beating it to death normally. Oh, no.
That sucked.
I could also cheese the guy over here.
On the bridge.
I didn't do that either.
No, I didn't unlock all the nerks.
How much do I need to level up?
Oh, perfect.
Intelligence.
The only thing that gives me like 70? I don't know. Not even.
It's not even gonna be there. It's not nighttime.
Albinarx's mo- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I did that. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I did. I could- I don't feel like farming like that again. I don't-
I did that for four hours and I got four million runes. It was too long.
I was like, what am I doing?
I'm just gonna go to the- Nope, that's not what I meant to do. I'm just gonna go to the-
We're gonna have to toggle the thing first.
Hello, hi, welcome in. Maybe a lot of new faces in here today because it's-
I don't usually stream this early in the morning. I hope everybody is doing well.
I hope everybody is doing well. I know some Snow Berries are in the chat,
so I know if you want to go attend the member stream, please.
This is a reminder to go watch Icy's member stream and go watch the room with her.
And I hope you have a lovely time with Icy, my lovely Snow Berries.
Am I gonna have enough rooms to level this? I don't even know.
Quite expensive. Oh.
I don't have a somber agent-dragging smithing stone.
I thought she's about doing a member's watch along. I don't know. I can't think right now, bro.
How do I not have a somber smithing stone 5? I thought I- whatever.
Oh, I have to- okay.
Nah, I don't really care about that too much. It's at 9, so that's fine, I guess.
I need to level my intelligence because look how it scales. The scale is fucking D.
Yeah, I don't need a plus 10.
I'm kind of- I'm kind of- can I?
I wanted to use my classical wonder psychic so I could see what it scales when I use it.
Some more decks.
Yeah.
Wait.
This is bigger than Limgrave. It looks like a hand. A little fingy's coming out.
Okay, so he wants me to go all the way over here and then go all the way around, all the way up here.
Go up this here. Go across here and then go over here.
I can dual wield the moon veil. Do I have the dual wield- do I have the dual?
I don't think I have the dual wielding medallion because then I would throw that on. What the fuck am I doing?
Pressing the wrong button, that's what the fuck I'm doing.
Interesting.
Cool.
Yeah, I have two hand and sword spellmen.
What that?
I like how pretty that looks. It's so pretty.
Pretty.
Let's do- I don't know if it'll be too heavy. It might be heavy load if I try to dual wield.
Yeah.
If I might- I might leave that as is then.
It's- it's- it's- It's not as heavy as it is then.
Shut up, guys. I hate that I just look so unfashionable during all of this.
I'm just- I'm just a big boy.
...
ppupupupupupupupupupupupupupupupupup!
Ibi-bi-bi-bi.
You have a child...
...
who is bluzzy.
He stretch
Like it the chin scratchies
You like the chin scratchies?
All big yon from the big man you gonna dust again
That's me
He's doing fine fire this morning snuggle played a little bit just curled up in her bed napping
This is for mortal posh like me. I
Don't know. I don't know anything. I don't I'm not looking. I'm not paying attention to stats. I just want cool stuff
I just want to be fashionable
Okay
Okay, you did that
Why do you have six million rooms just sitting in the bank?
Yes, I got that
Okay, we got to go through the dragon's pit
I don't think I'm strong enough to kill Rinali at Rilano
I can try but I'm just gonna
What is that is that a marionette? I don't even know anybody down here. Yeah, this is a dog
Oh, it's Beastman's it's Beastman's
Oh
Oh, I didn't mean to rock off you like that. Oh, you're I you're really strong. I'm gonna run away now
This is nice, this is cool out
This is cool. This is nice. Is anything in here that I can have like a cool weapon
Oh, I'm scratching my nose
I'm scratching my nose
I'm stuck I'm stuck these it's not very nice
Is
It chasing me this is cool. I like this area. Is that a boss over there?
Where am I
I can't go down way
Anybody around
No, okay
Hello
Be brave show no fear
Are you asking me to jump off?
Do I jump off?
No
That's not the focus right now, I don't want to have to run it back all around all these guys again
I
Not
No
Not the fucking worm not the worm I didn't want to deal with the worm
I
All right, anyways
What's that song by like is it called a cake?
She's going the distance
She's going for speed
And I'm going and I'm zooming and I'm going and I don't even know when I'm going and I don't
She's going the distance
Yeah cake of the band run
Run
Okay, there's a worm
Where is it
Oh
Can I please get up
Why the fuck can I stand like I don't know why all my animations take so long for me to move I don't
Would you love us if you were a worm as long as you don't hurt me
Then yes, but if you're a mean worm, then I don't know
That's where I go
I don't even know if I'm going the right way
Out
I wish there was a steak america worm is optional. Okay, that's what I thought
It's literally just fucking rocking my shit every time I walk in
Wish I could cast invisibility, but I do not use incantations
No, no, no, no, no, no
No, no, oh
What the fuck just happened I don't even did I just go in a fucking circle I did
I'm a little confused
Do I need a jump in the hole
I
It's the right way but how do I get past them
The one that said be brave. Oh, okay. All right
To the brave hole away
I'm gonna need a lore explanation for that because that doesn't make any sense
Uh, I didn't land in water I literally landed in fucking sand
That doesn't make any sense
I have to kill a boss
Oh, buddy, who are you ancient dragon, man
What the fuck was that?
Oh fucking went into that
Oh
No
Why did I try to cast
He is terrible poise
Okay, I can beat him. I can beat this guy. Okay, this is fine
Okay, this is he gravity. Oh fuck. Yay sweet stake america
I was gonna say I'm like if I have to keep running through that
Lightsaber fight
Has even more follow-ups if I mash. Yeah
Oh
I I thought I was on the animation I was
I'm trying to mash but it's not really working
You die to this guy more to the first DLC boss
Well, I'm about to die to this guy more than the first DLC boss, but I use my summons for the DLC boss
The first one for the thing and that's why I was able to beat him so fast
Mash the skill button
What do you mean
I
I'm confused
Hit l2
What the fuck
Whoa
I was pressing the wrong thing. Holy shit. Um
Sick
I'm gonna get ya. I'm gonna get ya. I'm gonna get ya. I'm gonna get ya. I'm gonna get start throwing away for me
That's enough. Come here
I have something to tell you come. Yeah just like that
Yeah, all right
Oh he rolled out of the fucking way
Ah
I realized they have like really cool animations
For um
What oh, I wasn't looking at my health. Um, they have really cool animations for a lot of the weapons like I know for midras that um
When in midra with midra's sword, it's pretty sick
Like I like that you you it's like grab to sword grab I want to I want to probably get also
Uh plus 10 midra sword or late plus nine on these
Oh
You're, like, really far away, I don't mean.
Oh, you can heal, too?
You fucking son of a bitch.
It only works on tarnished?
What?
Really?
Not stupid.
Squeeze the pouch for good luck.
Thank you, boomi.
What?
I pressed the button, but I suppose my timing was off.
What the fuck?
He's easy.
He's easy, bro.
He's literally so easy.
He's so easy.
I was getting my timing wrong.
Oh, I forgot to spam.
Ow.
Are you so fast for no reason?
Someone is vacuuming the hallway.
Can you do a dragon thing, please, so I can heal?
That works.
Come on, you're not even hard.
I'm just playing stupid, though.
He's naked?
Oh, yeah.
I heard that you can be a dragon.
Here we go, Talisman.
What would that be?
Sometimes I think he's going to do this attack, and then he doesn't do it, and then he stabs me.
No, no.
How did you...you have a very long range.
He's not even good.
Like, it's not a hard boss.
He literally isn't...it's not even a hard boss.
I'm rolling at the wrong time.
No.
Nice.
What the fuck was that spam?
He just R2 spammed me.
Did you see that shit?
I'm trash, bro.
I'm literally trash.
All right.
Tula, let's go.
You hear me cracking my shit? Let's go.
Boomi, it's because you left.
You're my lucky charm.
Oh, why don't I do this?
I'm so stupid.
Duh.
So that's what happens when I actually lock in brothers.
That's what happens.
I should have beat him like two tries ago.
Or this.
Yippee.
I don't like the hands on those dragons.
I think I have to pee.
It's a pee break.
The new sword's pretty sick.
It's a good sword for me because I can just spam stuff.
I have PRB.
Hello, sorry.
I was flipping the pancake kitty.
And now I'm moving for a snack.
I didn't really buy these snacks when I went out for groceries.
I'm probably going to stop at a certain time to eat before I do make lunches out of a snack.
That's true, it is so forwardy.
I really want a burrito now.
I've gotten in my head.
No Grace left alive.
Did somebody gift while I was peeing?
Who was it?
All the Grace went back to hiding, to lurking.
Don't worry, I still care about you.
I care about all of my children.
Not gift, join.
Oh nice, welcome.
Welcome new emotes tier or members.
Conducted a soul to the emotes?
What does that mean?
Oh my god, boomi.
Except for thing?
Oh do you mean the turtle talisman?
Is that what you mean?
I'm just staring at chat.
You can't eat the crumbs from the skull.
Except my two top children.
Newly improved.
It's a two headed turtle.
Well there's two that died.
Yeah, wait hold on.
The first one, let me look.
This one, every time it just keeps acting.
I feed it and I give it toys to play with
and it ends up being sick in like an hour.
I don't understand.
I just have a sickly ugly child.
I don't.
Okay if I go to status and I go to profile.
So where are the past Thomas?
How do I look at the past Thomas?
It's not showing me.
Some of the stuff is in a weird fucking spot.
I don't even remember where the past Thomas are.
Oh here it is.
So I had Goza Ruchi and Yume Miti.
Yume Miti died sad and so did Goza Ruchi.
But I took care of Yume Miti.
Because I made them into pecorra.
Now I want a pecorra.
You know it's like a food?
It's pretty tasty.
I think it's a zit on my shoulder.
What the fuck?
And then there's what's this one called?
This one's called Saberichi.
No I didn't. I didn't make them into marine.
I never dressed them up as marine.
VTuber Enjoyer. What has happened so far?
There's a cry here! Everybody jump on him!
Jump on him!
Kill him!
I'm kidding.
Okay now you're fine.
Bro you're fine bro.
You're fine. Don't worry about it.
We're just messing with you.
You always bully the newcomers.
You bully them with affection.
Alright.
It's just called a deer.
We kid deer. It was old lady voice.
We kid deer.
I'm generally surprised with this Pokemon.
This Tamagotchi hasn't died yet.
I just want it to die so I can move on to the next one.
Because this one I just can't stand.
Because I do everything for it.
Oh you still got one that was talking a lot.
Now they're lurking. Good job.
Thank you no one special for the gifted.
Why does she bully us?
I don't know.
I'm the dom of the deer.
Your girl failure dog.
What the foot of the dragon peak.
Alright.
He said...
So I did that.
Got that grace and I have to go around...
To the dragon.
Oh shit. That looks kind of crazy.
There's a lot of dragons here.
Alright.
There's going to be more dragons here.
I...
I think we should hop on a horse.
Where? I thought I rested at that side of grace.
I suppose I did not?
Question mark?
Yes but even me.
Even with no twists and turns?
I will get lost.
I thought you would know this about me already.
Ladies and gentlemen we have been joined by Reina.
Hello Miss Chunk.
Hi.
Are you going to lay down so I have a place to put my headphones?
Because like you're...
You're going to lay on top of my headphones and then pull them out which I don't want.
Hi.
Where are you smelling my breath?
Do I need to brush my teeth?
I haven't brushed my teeth today so...
I would be understandable.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Fucking...
Reina what was that?
She just did a whole loop.
Do you loop on my chest?
Slash tummy.
Pet pet pet pet.
Pet pet pet.
Do you want a smooch?
There's your smooch.
We're just...
We're just getting scottotree fragments.
And I just got a sword.
Yep.
I can't get torrent yet.
What am I doing?
You mean...
Torrent.
Thank you.
Frag out!
Okay.
So...
We just go down here.
Then we loop around.
We got some...
Weird fucking looking dragons here.
Oh I have a lot of money.
I have a lot of money.
Hold on.
What did you guys suggest that I put?
Not that it matters.
I can always respect.
But like...
Should I put...
it?
Why is everything turning yellow?
What does that mean?
Am I maxed out?
That's interesting.
Should I put it into...
Oh.
It's in the DC land.
Okay.
Got you.
I didn't know that.
Nifty.
60 vigor?
Yeah.
Should I just try to work up to 60 vigor?
Or should I get a little bit more int?
Or a little bit more dex?
So vigor should be 60.
Let's do it then boys.
Everybody...
Everybody wants me to do the...
My ear is itchy.
Rena's resting on my arm. Hold on.
Are you guys having a good morning?
I hope you're productive.
I hope you're productive with me in the background.
Hope Rena doesn't chew on my fucking headphones.
I don't think she's noticed them yet.
Thank God.
They're like ripable her neck.
And cats can't really see you right in front of them.
So it's a little bit difficult.
What? I was looking at my cat
and I didn't see what direction I was running in.
My booby itches.
It's the booby.
Booby has been itched.
We commend.
Yeah.
Yeah, don't get distracted.
Just have me on the background. You're not missing much.
I'm just falling off cliffs.
Like so.
Does it want me to go...
Around this way?
Okay, well...
What is this?
Bail!
You think what's his face was here?
Look at the E.P. Dragon.
Wait, why does Torrance's nose look purple?
I was weird. It looked like...
Wait, what the fuck? What's up with Torrance's eye?
Torrance has like a very human eye.
It didn't look like it was like the normal
horse eye.
I can't jump down from there.
What's the point of this?
Dumb.
Bail!
Oh, Terror Incarnate!
Well...
Something doesn't seem right here.
Okay, then I just keep...
Just going this way.
I need to scratch my boob.
Why is my boob itchy?
I'm scared that Bail's going to jump from the sky.
And get me.
I don't know where he is.
Not...
I haven't explored.
I've only looked at lore in some boss fights.
I haven't
done like actual map exploration
videos.
Why is that sheep so fucking huge?
Some of these are super sheep.
Yeah, surprise!
Did I go the right way?
I did. Okay, this isn't that bad.
And then we come to
a Dragon Communion church, I believe.
Yes, yes.
Quite. That is terrifying.
Indeed, yes.
Is that the stake American? Why is that...
Oh.
No.
Hey!
I like your fit.
You're a dragon person.
Are you, like, a land sacks
who became a human?
I will not partake.
Yeah, I don't want to be a dragon.
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
Thank you for the offer. That was very, very kind.
Very kind.
You know, you know what's funny?
Placidus sacks
is not as big as this dragon.
This dragon is fucking huge.
The dragon that fell...
Oh, I can't do anything.
The dragon that fell
on Lindell. I forget what its name is.
Whatever the fuck.
Yes, yes, yes, priestess.
Can I climb into your mouth?
I feel like I should be able to.
They are not as big as these dragons.
Like, I don't like them.
Like, who killed this guy?
I don't know. I don't know the lore of this.
I haven't looked it up yet, but I will.
I feel like he should have more teeth.
I feel like there should be a second row of teeth.
This is very cool, though.
Like a funky chin moment
mouth thing.
I don't know.
Yeah, but he has a lot of heads.
That doesn't matter.
That's fucking humongous.
And so is Greyl,
but she's old.
Rena is purring, and she's leaning
against my headphone wire, and it's like
I can hear her purrs in my ear.
That's so weird.
What are you doing, Rudy?
It's vibrating up my headphone wire.
I'm not saying size doesn't mean power.
I'm just wondering,
I know Godwin killed
the one that was over Lindell,
and it was a brutal bloody fight.
But like,
I'm, this is, yeah, this is
this is a big ass fucking dragon, dude.
Where are my fucking Caleb? Why is everything so red?
Rena, your purrs are throwing me off,
because it sounds like it's in-game.
I wish you guys could hear this.
It's such an interesting, it's almost like it's on a 3DO.
Okay.
Yippee!
He said, once you're at the red flowers,
you're in the right direction.
These are cool.
They look like chameleons.
Chameleons? Chamelea flowers?
Camillo flowers.
Cami-cami-ha flowers.
Turtles! Look at
dogs!
Wait, what's that?
Is there a lobster going to
show up and fuck me up?
Nope, just a tibia mariner.
I'm living its best life.
Oh, I fell.
Sorry, Rena, I have to move
the headphone wire.
Your purrs are nice to listen to.
It's such a scale, though.
Alrighty.
Do I have, like, everything?
What am I doing?
Okay.
So many pools now.
Functional.
I think I have to keep going this way.
Let me look at the
thingy.
What do you mean this area?
Yup.
Oh.
I'm going to fight a hippo.
Guys, I'm going to fight a hippo.
What the fuck? Did you see that bird
just, like, move?
I was like this, and then, like,
wait, wait, wait, wait, hold on.
Do you see it jump when I
It, like, loads in.
Why does it do that?
That's such a weird thing.
What the fuck?
Alright, bro.
Time to find a hippo.
That boss music is terrifying.
Ah.
What's that?
Ghost flame bloom.
Ooh, what's this?
No.
It's hippo time.
Um.
Hi.
Hi, hippo.
What? No, hippo.
Oh, you're kind of slow.
Ow. No, you're not.
Wow, I did
kind of barely any damage to you.
Okay.
Alright.
At least your damage isn't too hard.
What's that?
I didn't get to see it.
Oh, you just
destroyed my pose.
Boys.
Oh, I thought I was scratching my chin
and then I didn't press the B button in time.
Can you give me a second?
Hold on.
I'm a little
fascinated by you.
Because you're like
very slow.
You pack a wallet.
It's good to stay like on you
and then roll
on the inside.
I'm not
rolling as much as I want to.
Oh, okay.
I didn't mean to do the third one.
I
rolled forward, but it didn't
have too slow.
Alright.
Oh, you did that twice.
I didn't really dodge that well.
Okay.
What did I do to knock you
just that much health?
I simply don't recall.
I think
I thought I had the timing right,
but I guess I don't.
I guess it was the bleed.
I only have one flash left.
Yeah, I just fucked it up, though.
No.
I'm not really doing that good.
You're a weird hippo.
Oh,
I pressed it at the same time you bit me.
Yes.
I know.
I know it's like there's another dude that
rides a hippo.
It's a good hippo practice.
I don't feel like hunting for
golden seeds, to be honest with you.
Oh.
Those will just take too much time.
Okay, now I know how to fight the hippo.
I know how to fight the hippo.
Help.
I'm gonna sneak up on him.
I'm gonna sneak up on the hippo.
He hasn't seen us yet.
Here we see the Elton Ring hippo
in its natural habitat.
Roaming.
Okay, well...
Oh, I forgot you do it twice.
I jumped over that!
I jumped over that.
You whip around way too fast.
I don't feel like you should be able to whip around that fast.
Ow.
I did better the first time.
Why are you so powerful?
Stop it.
I jumped right into your jaws.
I deserve to die.
I don't know why the camera was like that.
I thought it killed itself for a second.
No, please.
Can I please heal?
Yeah, let's do a little.
Hi.
I...
No, I don't time that right.
I just really should just roll past your jaws.
Oh, my fucking god.
I am not doing the timing right at all.
You got ugly fucking mouth.
Oh, my god.
I...
I'm locked in stunned animations.
I feel like...
I don't know why I suddenly don't have the timing right.
Okay.
Hmm.
I wonder what the healing fast tastes like.
Strawberry blood.
Sun kiss.
I feel like it would taste like Coca-Cola.
Or Dr. Pepper.
I'm going to say Dr. Pepper flavored glass.
Or a Shirley Temple.
Or like a lime ricky.
I don't know if people know what that is.
It's essentially like a Shirley Temple.
I don't know if people know what a Shirley Temple is.
Oh.
Okay.
We're going to do this the right way.
I don't...
I'm pretty sure I can...
If I do it with Torrent, I...
I feel like...
I'm just going to keep missing all my hits.
Like, I swear I roll and I jump and I miss that.
I...
For whatever reason.
I rolled past it.
I rolled past that.
I...
My hitbox.
Come over here.
I don't want to be near that thing.
I...
Maybe I will have to do it on Torrent.
What the fuck?
Should I not lock on?
I'm doing better when I can't
fucking see him for some reason.
I didn't roll in time.
My nuke is getting fucking stomped.
I hate his mustache.
I regret that he does it twice.
I rolled.
Oh, he does it twice.
I forgot.
I keep saying he does it twice.
Whoa.
Why isn't the camera moving?
I was trying to move the camera back
and it wasn't moving.
I...
I was trying to move the camera back
and it wasn't moving.
Oh my god.
Don't fuck it up.
Okay, I was gonna say, like Jesus Christ.
Alright.
Nifty.
I don't think that really matters.
I'm just gonna go teleport.
I'm honorable.
I have to respect the beast.
I can't sully it with magic.
I was kidding.
Alright.
I think it locked into one of those
and that's why it got fucked up.
Let me just grab this so it doesn't pop up on my radar thingy.
Alright, what's next?
Wait.
Wait, the NPC...
When I step into the shadow, keep the NPCs going
to a second fucking phase.
That is such a weird thing.
Huh?
Explain.
I have confusion.
Something really important happens.
I thought...
That sucks.
It kind of sucks
because if you're just playing around willy-nilly
you get soft luck out of a lot of shit.
Um...
Alright.
Damn.
Uh, whose side quest should we do?
Should I go try to kill Lorelauna?
Raina's licking my arm.
Let's try Lorelauna.
Alright.
So like if I didn't talk to certain people
then...
What the fuck am I doing?
If I don't talk to certain people
I get locked out of their quest.
Did I talk to everyone?
Hi, Raina.
Not the sweet boy though, yeah.
Let's try it.
Okay.
She is crazy poise though.
I feel like I should dual wheel...
Oh, I can't dual wheel.
I'll just waste the flash.
Oh, she just fucks me up.
She does take a little breaks though
after her fucking little massive swings.
Like a lot of lore dialogue?
I see, I see.
Aw, let me fix the chat again.
I wish chat would work.
That would be great.
I need to find another website.
Hi, Raina.
Okay, time to try to fight Rinala
for three hours.
Relana, whatever the fuck her name is.
I feel like I wanna almost take off all my fucken...
Hold on, okay.
Hold on, I have cat hair in my nose.
I need to see if I can find Rinala or not?
Please!
Hold on. Hold on. I have cat hair in my nose. Hold on. I have cat hair. Stop. I have cat hair. Time out!
Time out!
I think we all did use the same chat thing at um, I won't point, but I don't think they used it anymore.
I
Didn't summon Freya for the dancing lion was I supposed to I just killed him with my thingy
Cat hair my weakness. I'm just hoping Raina doesn't chew on my thing. What is she weak to oh, I can
Do I have to do something for her?
I'm hanging out
Hi
Oh
Let's go leader we got this
Go on leader get them
We're sizing each other up
Oh my god, holy shit
Her poise is I'm gonna die
No, that's not what I meant to grab damn leaders do put it in fucking work. I'm not gonna lie
Can we get some blood proc?
Yeah, that's pretty nice. She's weak to lightning
Oh, was that uh, was that uh
Oh, yeah, because she's standing on fucking water
But I don't have any incantations for that shit
I wish there was lightning sorcery like why isn't there such thing as lightning sorcery?
Oh nice skadoosh
If they hate sorcery, why would they do this?
What is that?
All these incantations I don't have access to because I don't use faith. What is this actual spirit? That's kind of terrifying
Of human build
Golden vow would be pretty nice
You'll feel from afar good for summons
Do I have
This is where I actually get to the nitty gritty
I don't have any lightning pots
Because then I would throw lightning pots at her
I don't have the cookbook for that. I believe that is in
I believe
I would sleep her if I have the
She's not weak she has flame
Oh
Yeah, I don't I don't have any lightning resin or uh, I mean lightning grease. Yeah, I provided the same fucking thing
Cause it's kind of heavy
It's so weird that lightning is tied to faith
Yeah, that's true I could
Um
I don't have any cracked ponds
I never got any cracked pots
Little just brute-forcer
Yeah, but I only have one eat. I only have one Trina Lily. I have one pot
Um
I don't want to use pots because like I just know I'll just fucking waste them all trying to craft them
Hey
I can't jump that time
You have crazy reach
She literally fucking dances like millennia
Oh, sorry, I should have jumped over that. What the fuck? Where's army?
She always follows up a true carrion princess. Yeah, this is do fucking shit to her
Hmm
I might have to get a lightning weapon boys
I could try a blood build up with my ash
You
No, I I I prefer to solo uh her or try or with a summon
I I try to do everything by myself unless I'm really struggling like with those um
Fucking virgin abductors. I was just annoying
Um, you know, it's let's get lead in here and then I'll have two ladies
Can I do both? I don't know why does it take forever for her to fucking load in that doesn't make any sense
You're pretty neat neat looking
I
Why this is insane I can't even hit her
She have a second phase
We are not doing any fucking damage it's really just blood
Holy shit, don't die
You
Can I repost her can I repost her no
I should just I wish I just had to heal because then I would just heal her. What is this? This is just a gang bang. I feel bad
I
My game just lags so hard. Oh, why did I heal? I didn't need to I was looking at her health bar
Can I repost her? I don't know gang up on her ass gang up on her ass
Ah
Don't die
No, don't die
Ha ha ha
Okay, NPCs increase the boss difficulty, yeah
Yeah
Yeah, there's gang gang bang strat. I like gang bang strat. Let's try it with just the ash
See
Oh
Yeah, go I grow like I'm not even attacking you. Okay, let's see. Oh, you're gonna kill that in like five seconds
I
Just want to do blood build up any of this
Okay, that actually really helps blood build up just probably no phase two any second I would prefer
What the fuck
Uh, I don't remember her doing that before
Oh man
Oh
I didn't know that I didn't know that with the NPCs were gone. That was a big sword
I know she's strong to magic
I'm just doing that because it helps with the blood build up because then I can just spam it
And then I because I'm moving around my hitbox is is a little bit different and like I teleport a little bit
And so it's hard for her to get me
You
You can get the magic great shorts to uses it's not like a carrion
slicer, right
Rina, I don't know if I could do this with you on my lap. I'm kind of like I'm not in the best position right now
Of course
No problem
Oh
Oh, okay
I see I see sorry to smack my mic
Rina
I'm gonna give you a hug and then put you on the ground. No, okay. She climbed my shoulder and
Oh
Oh, you want to hug Rina? I'll give you a hug. I'll give you a big hug Rina
I want her weapon so bad and then I want to get like a dual wielding talisman
There you go
Uh stretch my leggies
Okay, you know what I think the gang bang method was it
I think I'm just gonna cheese her with the gang bang method
Hurry up
I hate that they load in like they're actually being fucking summoned from a multiplayer game. It doesn't make any sense to me
She's fucking off me. I'm just hoping she wouldn't do that. Okay bring her in the water boys bring her in the water
Boys water boys bring her in the water
Oh my god bring her in the fucking water
Guys please bring her over here
Ah my mimic is just fucking rocking her shit
I can't even see what the fuck is happening bro
Anytime I try to get over there. They're just fucking going crazy and I my uh thinking this freaks out
Hit the blood proc hit the blood proc
Okay back the fuck up
I forgot that that is such a huge fucking reach for no reason
Oh what I didn't even know that was going for me. I don't understand how she can how
How
Lita do something
Yeah, it's gonna be careful
You
Brother that's
Oh, I thought was like she gone. She's like fuck this shit. I'm out
What if I like go in when she like hasn't exactly been summoned yet?
And she still show up I don't fucking know
Oh
Get her in the water get in the fucking water
Why I don't know why I did that. Um, okay, there's gonna gain
That's gonna aim at me do it. Let's do it
Get her I can't even do anything
Oh, no, I can she's gonna kill me for it. No
I
Really wish I had the fucking deal because then I would just fucking let her die
Summons
Okay, I'm gonna aggro me
Lita goes fucking hard
All right
This will take a while the the time until my doom stream will probably be Rilana
Oh
Okay, that's good. I don't really need this right now
I don't really need this right now
You
Yippie
Wait, why am I wearing this in the first place?
Was I just doing it for poise? I still only I only have 40 poise
I'll actually know I have 61 poise but then I have 40 if I put that on
Yeah, I know yeah, that's true. That's true
I just can't see past my giant bod my hot bod
All right, let's uh, let's do that
Come on Lita Lita. Oh, sorry. I'm in the fucking equipment screen
I
Really killed us yet
Why do we have her against the wall like this? I just don't think it's a good idea. I also can't see what the fuck is going on
Oh my gosh, you're gonna kill me
Oh
That was a terrible what the fuck
What did that clip through the fucking floor that was so weird
I feel like
I
My frame rate is being so bad right now
I'm lagging and there's a lot happening and I don't know what to do with myself
Armor means nothing compared to fashion
Ma'am
Hello
Stature what
Okie-dokie
Okie-dokie, let's go
I'll just eat that and then I'll heal. No, right. Let me get out of the fucking way
I don't know why
Oh, are they gonna aggro me usually they aggro me. Oh, I'm surprised. She's a lot of health Lita. I'm surprised with that
Oh
My god, I'm so close to death. Give me out of here. Give me out of here. Give me out of I was locked into an animation because of lag
I don't
I feel like I should just be meeting Lita
Although I do like the blood build up the mimic gives me
Because like the fraying FPS is just really bad
I
Am epi
Epi epi epi
The great epi maybe I should wear a light
You think me making me was solid. All right, I'll try it. I'll try this
Get in the water
Get in the fucking water
How does she cancel me out? I don't
I'll lead it as blood build up too
I
Heal please
No, fuck I missed it
Need that riposte
Oh
Wow, we didn't do any fucking damage at all
But I'm seeing blood hit
Not the dad jokes, okay, let's try me and just the mimic
I
Why is Rwanda so hard?
Okay
Please don't kill me right off the rip
No
I can't
I feel like I'm fighting Malania all over fucking again
And sometimes I can't tell if she's gonna attack me or the thing it's like she's all over the fucking place
Oh see like I didn't know those are gonna be on me
My mimic's about to die and it's just me
I need to heal
No, no, no, no, no
Oh, I thought I jumped over that
No, this isn't fair. This is a nice
Yeah
Yeah, it's really malania but even more fucking aggressive because malania sometimes just blacks up
Those backs off and just like stares at you for a bit and then she'll be like
Woo, and she's left. She's a little bit faster. I feel like but she usually she'll stay in one spot
When she does like some stuff. Okay. It looks like gang bang is how it's gonna be
Oh
Did I oh my god fucking hurry up
Okay, I'm gonna let it aggro her first
Oh my god, I'm not locked on so I can't see where the fuck she is
Lock on her lock on her. Thank you
It has a lot of health so we're fine
Oh
Fuck my poise I just
I
Or someone else
We're not even doing as much damage as I was hoping
All right
I
Stop using fucking that sort of fucking magic on him
Oh, give me that
All right
Oh
No, oh my gosh the fault like you think she's only gonna do it like once or twice, but then she'll just keep doing the follow-up
You think moon veils attack is better because it doesn't move you
I don't I have to disagree
Honestly if I had bloodhounds fang that'd be pretty fine like you could probably beat it with bloodhounds fang
Because I think the ability to move and like dodge her is very important
Because otherwise you're like you're gonna be like me and just spam roll the entire time
Hello, hi
Hello, hi welcome in
What
I
Oh
Beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep
What is that gonna say I forget don't worry about it
What
Not I'm not locked on I'm I
Like honestly, I'm tempted to even like do the backhand blade and level that the fuck up and try to get her with it
And add blood or like poison
I'm kind of tempted to do that
Let's try it
What am I doing
Yeah, like blind spot would be good
Did I get blood how I think I did get what husband I
Don't think I have enough decks for it though. I think I needed more decks for the oh what's this?
This is only fourth. Oh movie does more this is 55 great katana
Can I this night on a quip this help
Raina, I can't see raina. No, this is not rain. Okay fine. I guess you can just be there
Um
She's just purring at me
I need 15 strength for that
I
Don't have enough fucking strength for the shit raina you're laying on my headphones
All right, oh I already fucking leveled up the
What the fuck I don't even recall doing that. Um
That's funny
What is the perfume bottles do what? Oh
I need faith for that
I've actually never used the perfume bottles
Who is Chibi, I don't know what Chibi is
I
Should I do a little lightning backhand blade you think
I think that would be good
I need money I have no money. Can you do it for free?
Can you do it for free?
What is that?
Tiny fire steaks
interesting
I know I have fucking shadow runes. Okay. I was gonna say oh
That's 12 that's a lot. I don't need that much
I
Think I'm cute
Just kept going cuz it let me I
Don't know this will do anything
This looks so fucking
I hate it
Guys are the fuck am I I look so fucking goofy
I
Was I
Chibi when the baby with the oh
The spam the ash and you should stomp her. Yeah, let's see. Let's see
I
Wait, hold on I'm a little confused
So to be honest with you what I might do is
I might two hand can I I might double up summon them like that
And then switch while they're doing a detain go
To the moon fails so I can get blood they can get
That
Or I can just do one of each
Yeah, I'll do that. So then they have double and I'll just have like one
Yeah, yeah, yeah, sure. I don't know. I don't fucking know what I'm doing. I'm not smart. I'm not smart
Oh my god, please don't kill me right off the rip. I forgot to heal
Oh
Can we get her in the water, please
Can we get her can we get her in the water, please can we like get her in the water, please is that
like guys I don't
I'm kind of trying to get her to aggro me and come over here, but she's not taking the bait
No, yeah, I don't
So I just sit here and watch I don't I feel like a cuck
I don't I don't have to do anything though. They're kind of just doing their own thing
All right, now she's in the fucking water so now we can
Okay
We need is about to die
I
Can't recall stir
I wish
Okay, I kind of I think if I if I enter the fight early
I
Oh
Okay, so we need to get her in the water
The cook puddle
So we need to get her towards the fucking water so I'm gonna
Guys we're just posting it here, so I'm gonna
Move her
This kind is two-handing does that count
Is it a sepa? Yes, no, I'm getting conflicting information or what I need a dual wielding talisman
Maybe I don't know
Drive safely
Holding one. Yeah, I thought so, okay
I
Damn, I thought I would be able to dodge that
Oh
No
What I didn't mean to do that, but sure, you know what fuck it
Oh, I died I was paying attention my fucking no
Oh
Guys this is hard
This is hard
It's also hard to do cuz Rena is in my life, but it's we persevere
What if they wait wait what if
No, that would take so long for me to sweat I wish I could
What the fuck am I pulling that from
My ass what's suppose that I'm a man of three swords. That's why I have that on my back
Okay, right now, I'm so sorry, but you have to get up cuz I can't reach my controller properly. They're a big body on me
She looks personally offended
She be a Zorro what no I'm one of the three musketeers get it right
I
Have one more hour to feed defeat this boss cuz then I'm gonna go take a break from it
Yes, I have an intelligence be why do you think I have magic sword
I want to give them a I want to give them this cuz maybe they'll do bleed and they'll do lightning if I do this
We'll see we'll see
You need to get her in the fucking water, I don't know why we're not
I
There you go
No, don't tell me yet
All right, that was a weird buy but okay go off this
It's raining
Fucking riposte her ass
What was that that was so weird
Oh, no, not my
Oh
They're still aggro on her
I
I'm running out of I might need more stamina for this
Oh my god
If I jumped and did it then I should have been fine
I
Think stab piece of pew pew. Yeah, uh, it's it's easier to do it stabby I suppose. All right, um
Pull at the wacky sword
This was working it was effective
I'm gonna keep at it and one of these times it's just gonna stick
I
Let me both get blood
And then we also get lightning
Oh
Oh, I wasn't paying attention to my health
Guys why is Rilana so annoying?
Like generally so annoying
Rilana stop
I just want your damn fucking swords
You beat her in one try. What was your build? What was your level and build?
How many hours do you fucking have in elderly?
Although I do like watching people who like know her moveset
um
Like fight her and like beat her in one shot like I saw someone like no deaths
The dlc for all the remembrance bosses and bail and I was like
I wish I was that fucking good, but I'm not
Oh no my internet
My internet is going
I
Help help everything's laggy
Help help help
YouTube studio is like not working properly
I'll just sit here and wait for it to be normal actually wait while nobody can see quick
Oh
Wait
No the aggro please
Oh
Okay right now
I didn't summon anyone. I don't need anyone
Oh